شهدت ساحه دار الاوبرا المصريه انطلاقه
فعاليات الدوره الرابعه والاربعين لمهرجان
القاهره السينمائي الدولي المهرجان الذي
يعد الاقدم والاعرق على مستوى الشرق
الاوسط وذلك بحضور عدد كبير من نجوم
السينما المصريه والاجنبيه المهرجان يضم
اربع مسابقات واسبوع النقاط الى جانب
مسابقه الافلام القصيره الفنان المصري
حسين فهمي يعود بعد سنوات ويراس المهرجان
من جديد
وهنشوف هنقدر نوصل ايه لكن الظروف فعلا
صعبه جدا والعالم كله بيمر بتجربه يعني
غير مسبوقه في الحقيقه
ااا بمعالجه بالافلام هي قضايا
سوسل اجتماعيه اكثر منها هي معالجه الفيلم
اللي هي بتفرق
ورؤيه المخرج اللي هي بتفرق
وثمانيه عشر في المنصيرا من اثنتين و 50
دوله شاركت في مسابقه المهرجان لهذا العام
منها نحو 30 فيلما عرضا عالميا اول ونحو
60 في المنطار لاول مره في الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا
الورش اللي بتتعمل حوالين المهرجانات
السينما في اسواراته
المصنع على مواكبه احدث ما وصلت اليه
السينما العربيه والعالميه من حيث
التقنيات والتجارب الشبابيه وذلك ضمن
فعالياته التي استمرت لتسعه ايام
[موسيقى]